time is up for Don Thompson having
failed to turn around the company's
lackluster performance McDonald's CEO
will be stepping down in March here are
5 of the worst numbers from Thompson's
tenure to help explain why he's out 13
the number of consecutive months
McDonald's domestic same-store sales did
an increase in November of 2014 alone
sales dropped 4.6 percent the worst drop
in more than a decade ate the number of
items McDonald's plans to cut from its
overly crowded menu in an attempt to
speed up service McDonald's has already
removed some of its quarter pounders and
wraps in certain markets around the
country 10 million
McDonald's wasn't able to sell roughly
10 million pounds of chicken wings had
bought for its mighty wings promotion in
the fall of 2013 the restaurant chain
was forced to sell the wings at a 3%
discount until supply right now 15 cents
that's the price per chicken nugget
during burger king's latest promotion
that's 5 cents cheaper than a McNugget
Burger King has been aggressively
challenging McDonald's position as the
low cost leader in fast-food fleet 3
percent that's the total amount
McDonald's stock have gained during
Thompson's 31 month tenure compare that
to shares of Chipotle which have gained
about 90 percent during the same period